neue Ausbildung das verspricht
Arbeitsminister Hubertus Heil und erntet
Kritik von allen Seiten das reicht nicht
zum Leben sagen die Sozialverbände dann
lohnt sich das Arbeiten gar nicht mehr
das sagen die Unternehmer das Bürgergeld
ist das gerecht unser Thema in der
phönix-
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ich darf Ihnen meine Gäste
vorstellen herzlich willkommen Dagmar
Schmidt von der SPD sie ist die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
zuständig für den Bereich Arbeit und
Soziales und geerdet wird sie in ihrem
Wahlkreis in Hessen der Lahn-Dill-Kreis
ist das herzlich willkommen Helena
Steinhaus Gründerin und
Geschäftsführerin des Vereins
sanktionsfrei der Vereinen unterstützt
Hartz IV Empfänger die von einer
Sanktion betroffen sind und das
Bürgergeld findet sie zu niedrig und
herzlich willkommen Stefan Schröter er
ist Unternehmer und Landesvorsitzende
Berlin des Verbandes die
Familienunternehmer das ist eine
Interessenvertretung von 180.000
inhabergeführten Unternehmen in ganz
Deutschland er findet das Bürgergeld ist
ein falscher Anreiz
und Tobias peter ist bei uns er ist
Parlaments Korrespondent für das
redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland rnd und
beobachtet all die Diskussion um Arbeit
und Soziales schon länger
Frau Steinhaus ihr Verein hat sich ja
jahrelang dafür eingesetzt also für das
Ende von Hartz IV in der jetzigen Form
und jetzt soll es das Bürgergeld geben
und das Bürgergeld heißt auch in den
ersten sechs Monaten wenn man es bekommt
soll es keine Sanktionen geben heißt das
ihre Forderungen sind erfüllt sie sind
zufrieden nein leider nicht und ich muss
sie auch korrigieren die Sanktionen sind
nicht ausgesetzt im ersten halben Jahr
sondern man wird nach wie vor
sanktioniert wenn man nicht zum Termin
erscheint ich glaube zum zweiten Termin
aber es gibt eine vertrauenszeit und das
ist schon anders als dass es vorher
anders es ist ein bisschen besser auf
jeden Fall und trotzdem gibt es nach wie
vor Sanktionen und leider ist auch der
Regelsatz einfach viel zu niedrig also
die Menschen können davon nicht
armutsfest überleben
Herr Schröter wenn Sie das Hören Frau
Steiner sagt das ist zu niedrig jetzt
sehen wir ja wir haben einen riesen
Personalproblem überall werden Leute
gesucht wenn der Hartz-IV-Satz jetzt
oder das Bürgergeld jetzt angehoben wird
um gut 50 Euro und dann noch wohn
Geschäftskosten bezahlt werden dann
sagen ja viele Unternehmer das dann
lohnt es sich gar nicht mehr zu arbeiten
was ist die Reaktion ihrer Unternehmen
auf die Vorschläge das ist tatsächlich
die Frage dass ich arbeit eben lohnen
muss und da müssen wir einfach schauen
dass dieser Unterschied zwischen der
Grundsicherung auf der einen Seite und
das was Menschen die im geringen
Verdiener Umfeld tätig sind dass diese
Differenz eben groß bleibt grundsätzlich
ist natürlich die Anhebung der Sätze
jetzt in dieser Situation mit den
gestiegenen Kosten durchaus
nachvollziehbar und für mich persönlich
auch okay also das finden sie richtig
aber dann ist gibt es doch weniger
Anreize zu sagen ja ich suche mir jetzt
einen Job ja natürlich wir müssen
schauen dass wir jeden der arbeitsfähig
ist dass wir den noch ein Beschäftigung
bekommen und da sitzt das Bürgergeld aus
unserer Sicht falsche Anreize in dem
eben die Bedürftigkeitsprüfung oder die
vermögensprüfung nicht konsequent
gemacht wird und natürlich diese
sanktionsfreie Zeit oder diese wo
weniger sanktioniert werden kann das
finden wir sind falsche Anreize aber
dieses Land braucht jeden Menschen der
Arbeiten kann meine mitunternehmerinnen
Unternehmer die suchen händeringend
Leute und glaube ich da setzt das
Bürgergeld so wie es jetzt geplant ist
falsche anreizung Frau Schmidt jetzt
haben sie gehört es gibt im Kritik von
verschiedenen Seiten die SPD hat ja sehr
lange mit mit Hartz IV gehabt jetzt das
ein neuer Begriff auch Bürgergeld was
entgegnen sie denn den Kritikern naja
das wenn es sozusagen von beiden Seiten
kritisiert wird ist ja vielleicht gar
nicht so schlecht ist wie wir es gemacht
haben und dass ich schon glaube dass wir
den Anforderungen sowohl die Frau
Steinhaus stellt als auch die Herr
Schröder stellt mit dem wie wir das
Bürgergeld jetzt konzipiert haben
gerecht werden führen sie es ein
bisschen aus also sowohl indem wir über
den Kern des neuen Bürgergeldes was ja
diese
Kooperationsvereinbarung ist nämlich der
Moment an dem man sozusagen gemeinsam
Partner eigentlich miteinander
verabredet welchen Weg man gehen möchte
welche Schritte man wieder geht und
welche Unterstützung man bekommt um eben
sein Einkommen auch wieder selber
sichern zu können und das ist sozusagen
der Kern und das wird auch erstmal
vereinbart ganz ohne dass da irgendeine
Androhung irgendeiner Sanktion drauflegt
sondern das wird partnerschaftlich
vereinbart und erst wenn das nicht mehr
stimmt also erst wenn sozusagen
Verabredungen die man gemeinsam
getroffen hat nicht eingehalten werden
oder wenn man erst sich verweigert
überhaupt zu einem Gespräch zu kommen
nur in diesen Fällen gibt es dann eben
auch die Möglichkeit die
Mitwirkungspflichten dann auch
einzufordern das ist die eine Seite und
die andere Seite für Herrn Schröter ist
dass meine Erfahrung auch mit den
Unternehmen bei mir im Wahlkreis ja
nicht die ist dass sie Bewerbungen haben
wollen von Menschen die einfach zehn
Bewerbungen schreiben müssen weil das
sozusagen die Aufgabe ist die ihnen
gestellt ist sondern die wollen
motivierte MitarbeiterInnen Mitarbeiter
die wollen qualifizierte Menschen die
wollen Menschen die sozusagen schon in
Arbeit auch sich reingefunden haben die
vielleicht die Möglichkeit hatten
Praktika zu haben wieder Tuchfühlung
aufzunehmen zum Arbeitsmarkt und
insofern werden wir auch dem
Fachkräftebedarf von Herrn Schröter
geben aber all das konnten doch alle
Mitarbeiter in den Arbeitsagenturen
schon jetzt machen warum hat das denn
also wo der woher nehmen sie das
Vertrauen dass das jetzt besser
funktioniert als vorher weil wir einen
ganz wichtigen Punkt ändern nämlich das
was man den vermittlungsvorrang nannte
das heißt man war immer verpflichtet zu
gucken wie kriege ich die Leute
möglichst schnell in irgendeiner Arbeit
und das sagen wir jetzt nicht mehr
sondern wir sagen wir gucken was kannst
du das ist das allererste was bringst du
mit was kannst du einbringen und dann
was willst du ist das realistisch und
was brauchst du um an Unterstützung um
das zu erreichen und das ist glaube ich
diese Möglichkeit mit einem erweiterten
Instrumentenkasten wie entfristen den
sozialen Arbeitsmarkt wir machen
Qualifizierung auch zu einer berufsaus
unmöglich wir machen auch Ausbildung in
Grundfertigkeiten viele Menschen
können nicht anständig Lesen und
Schreiben alles dies machen wir möglich
bevor die Menschen dann eben sich wieder
in Richtung Arbeitsmarkt orientieren und
das war bisher anders Herr Peter wie
positiv sehen Sie das wie stark
unterscheidet sich dieses neue
Bürgergeld also ist das wirklich eine
wirkliche Wende in der
Arbeitsvermittlung weil darum geht es ja
letztendlich ich glaube schon dass das
eine Wende ist es ist am Ende so dass
dieser Wechsel von Hartz IV zum
Bürgergeld wirklich eine Veränderung für
die Betroffenen bedeutet wirklich vieles
besser macht man kann sich die Frage
stellen warum die SPD so lange dazu
gebraucht hat aber das was frau Schmidt
gesagt hat dass der vermittlungsvorgang
Weg ist dass man wirklich diesen Fokus
legt auf Weiterbildung auf
Qualifizierung auch auf Ausbildung ist
natürlich etwas was einerseits den
Menschen hilft weil es kann ja nicht
darum gehen einfach nur zu sagen
irgendeinen bekomme was wolle und in
einem halben Jahr bist du wieder im
Jobcenter es hilft aber auch der
Gesellschaft in einer Zeit wo
Fachkräftemangel in Wahrheit das größere
Problem ist als Arbeitslosigkeit und
insofern ist da wirklich etwas zum
Positiven was da passiert ja Schulter
vertrauen sie darauf also wenn man
denken Sie das kann funktionieren dass
die Arbeitsagenturen eben das schaffen
also den Bedarf den sie in ihren
Unternehmen haben wirklich zu decken die
Arbeitsagenturen alleine werden das
natürlich nicht schaffen da muss man
deutlich früher ansetzen im Bereich der
Bildung wurde ein abendfüllendes
Programm separat sein ich denke dass
dieser weiterbildungsansatz auf jeden
Fall der richtige ist weil richtig hat
Frau Schmidt gesagt wir bekommen
Bewerbungen wo man schon im Turnus liest
dass das wirklich nur pro
forma-bewerbungen sind die brauchen wir
nicht deshalb denken wir aber eben auch
dass durchaus die Sanktionierung aber
auch gerechtfertigt ist Menschen müssen
sich eben auch
bewusst und gern bewerben ja und das ist
so die Frage ob das ob das dann eben
durch diese neue Regelung nicht
abgeschwächt wird ja aber Weiterbildung
diesen Ansatz den den können wir als
Familienunternehmer auf jeden Fall
begrüßen weil wir brauchen
ausgebildete Menschen wir reden ja nicht
mehr nur von Fachkräften wir reden ja
insgesamt von einem Arbeitskräftemangel
das ist ja nicht nur der hochgebildete
IT-Experte sondern sind ja Menschen die
wirklich auch einfache Tätigkeiten
machen die fehlen also das insofern
brauchen wir dann wiederhole ich mich
gar nicht so eine große Ausbildung nein
aber lesen und schreiben wir schon gut
Frau Steinhaus wie sehen sie es wenn man
sie das hören was frau Schmidt sagt
glauben Sie also trauen sie diesem neuen
Ansatz dass man das geht wirklich darum
die Leute mehr zu vermitteln und mehr
aus der aus der Sicht der
Arbeitssuchenden zu schauen ja ich finde
es wirklich gut dass der
vermittlungsvorgang abgeschafft wird das
ist ein riesen Fortschritt aber in all
dem fehlt mir die Perspektive oder ja
die Perspektive von Menschen die nicht
aktiv auf Arbeitssuche sind und auch gar
nicht auf Arbeitssuche sein können und
trotzdem Hartz IV beziehen und gar nicht
die Chance haben zeitnah daraus zu
kommen und über ja aber die sind in
Hartz IV und die bekommen auch dieses
Geld und die haben auch die Angst dass
sie sanktioniert werden können das total
wichtig über die zu sprechen das macht
super viele Menschen aus und über die
müssen wir auch reden und die können die
können wir nicht in Arbeit bringen da
sie sagen wir müssen einfach damit leben
in dieser Gesellschaft dass wir einfach
einen bestimmten Prozentsatz die können
einfach nicht arbeiten ja es geht ja zum
Beispiel um rund 1,75 Millionen Kinder
und Jugendliche die auch von Hartz IV
leben mit ihren Eltern in
Bedarfsgemeinschaften es geht um fast
eine Million Menschen die arbeiten aber
nicht genug verdienen und deswegen mit
der Grundsicherung aufstocken müssen
auch für die definieren wir ein
Existenzminimum obwohl sie arbeiten weil
sie schlecht bezahlt werden weil sie
vielleicht alleinerziehend sind und
nicht voll arbeiten können und das ist
nicht fair das ist ein nicht respektvoll
und da muss das Bürgergeld ansetzen und
und die beiden Gruppen sind um mal in
Hartz IV und wie sollen wir das trennen
da würden die sagen das müsste man
differenzieren also das tun wir ja schon
also das tun wir ja schon wenn ich auf
die die Kinder eingehen darf und
Jugendlichen wir haben im
Koalitionsvertrag die Kinder
Grundsicherung beschlossen das ist genau
der Schritt die Kinder die ja keine
kleinen Arbeitslosen sind da hat Frau
Steinhaus komplett Recht die man auch
nicht behandeln kann wie kleine
Arbeitslose die ihr draus zu holen
deswegen machen wir Kinder
Grundsicherung das machen wir nicht in
einem jetzt mit weil das eine sehr
komplizierte wirklich sehr
anspruchsvolle große Reform wird aber
das ist der Gedanke und jetzt wird sich
aber auch an dem Regelsatz orientieren
also an dem an dem Hartz IV oder
Bürgergeld Satz deswegen ist es wichtig
dass sehr eine vernünftige Höhe hat es
ist richtig dass der in der wie er sich
nachher berechnet das wird noch
Verhandlungsmasse im Koalitionsvertrag
sein im in den Koalitionsgesprächen dann
sein ich kann für meine Fraktion sagen
dass wir sehr stark darauf fokussieren
dass die Kinder Grundsicherung wirklich
ein großes Projekt und auch gut
ausfinanziertes Projekt von uns ist weil
genau das eine der Schlüssel ist wie ich
es schaffe die Kinder sozusagen den
Kindern eine eine gute und eine gerechte
und eine eine eine gleiche Perspektive
zu geben wie anderen Kindern und die
zweite Gruppe die nehmen wir ja schon
zum ersten Oktober in den Blick dadurch
dass wir den Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro
erhöhen ist das schon mal ein
Riesenschritt für diejenigen die
Vollzeit arbeiten den Schritt raus zu
machen und die Idee ist dann das
Wohngeld so anzupassen dass es für eine
größere Gruppe zugänglich wird eben auch
mit einem Heizkostenanteil auf der einen
Seite und auf der anderen Seite die
Kindergrundsicherung zu haben und das
heißt genau für die geringverdienten ja
und das ist auch der Anreiz immer wenn
man arbeitet hat man mehr und man
rutscht auch wenn man weniger das ist
wichtig und der bleibt genau dadurch
dass ich eben die geringverdienten
raushole und dann gibt es ein ganz
großes Problem bei denjenigen die nicht
voll arbeiten können weil meiner
Kinderbetreuung haben und das ist etwas
wo ich sage da gehört es wirklich noch
mal zu einer großen gemeinsamen
Anstrengung auch mit den Ländern endlich
auch Kinderbetreuung so sicherzustellen
dass man auch mehr Stunden arbeiten kann
wenn man alleinerziehend dabei was wie
stark der Anreiz ist zu arbeiten weil
das hört man ja jetzt auch in vielen
Reaktionen auf nach seit der Vorstellung
des Bürgergeldes viele gesagt haben ja
wenn ich dann wenn dann zwei Leute Hartz
IV oder das neue Bürgergeld
Entschuldigung bekommen und dann die
Kinder auch und dann noch Wohn- und
Heizkosten dann kommt das auch auf dann
kommt man auf locker 1500 Euro dann muss
ich doch gar nicht arbeiten gehen
Schröter wie sehr also hören Sie das
auch wie wird Ihnen das gespiegelt dass
Leute sagen die dann würde ich doch
einfach nicht arbeiten gehen ich
persönlich höre das in meinem Umfeld
jetzt nicht und auch in meinem bei
meinen Mitarbeitenden höre ich das nicht
weil man arbeitet ja nicht nur für Geld
das ist ja auch irgendwie eine Aufgabe
eine Beschäftigung eine Erfüllung
solltest zumindest sein aber gleich wo
sehen wir natürlich die Gefahr dass das
gerade eben im Bereich der der einfachen
Tätigkeiten der geringen qualifizierten
Tätigkeiten das dort die Motivation
nicht groß genug ist für drei vier
fünfhundert Euro die man vielleicht im
Monat mehr hat dann aber 40 Stunden in
der Woche eben das Haus zu verlassen
also die Gefahr die schon wobei es ja
aus meiner Sicht wirklich wichtig ist
dass man gering verdienende nicht
ausspielt gegen
Grundsicherungsempfänger es ist ja am
Ende so sie können jetzt sagen das ist
was dann jemand verdient das hat nicht
genug Abstand aber der Staat ist ja
erstmal gefordert das ist auch seine
Aufgabe nach der Verfassung zu schauen
was ist das Existenzminimum und das
müssen wir wirklich für alle Menschen
absichern
und dann ist die Frage jetzt gibt es
Mindestlohn jetzt gibt es die Inflation
die wieder ganz viel von dem was hätte
besser sein auffrisst und dann muss man
überlegen gibt es andere Wege wie man
Geringverdienern auch noch helfen kann
aber zu sagen die Menschen müssen
einfach weniger Geld bekommen in der
Grundsicherung damit der Abstand groß
genug ist das ja einfach nicht in
Ordnung wir können ja nicht sagen die
Menschen sollen oder frieren die lernen
müssen einfach wirklich nach oben es
geht nicht zu sagen dass geringen
qualifizierte Menschen für ihre Arbeit
wenig Geld bekommen sollen weil diese
Arbeit ist sehr sehr wertvoll die sie
machen und die hält unsere Gesellschaft
aufrecht ich verstehe überhaupt nicht
warum dafür weniger Geld gezahlt werden
soll als für gut qualifizierte Berufe
aber es muss ja auch irgendwo
erwirtschaftet werden also auch
Unternehmen müssen ja auch sozusagen
damit davon leben können und eben auch
damit rechnen deshalb noch mehr Schröter
ich höre das schon auch von Unternehmen
die sagen das lasse ich dann mal so und
wie sie sagen ja wir brauchen eben nicht
nur die Fachkräfte sondern auch geringen
qualifizierte wie können sich das
Unternehmen die jetzt auch unter hohen
Energiekosten leiden und all dem wie
können sich das Unternehmen dann leisten
ja wenn ich auf die Frage eine
umfassende Antwort hätte wäre ich mal
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich bei Herrn
Habeck im Büro sitzen nein aber Spaß
beiseite wir haben ja mit dem
Mindestlohn sind ja schon Schritte
gegangen worden es gab ja doch deutlich
eine Erhöhungen jetzt wenn man mal
schauen vor einem Jahr war er noch bei
10 € weiß ich nicht und jetzt kommen wir
ja zu den 12 €. das ist auch in Ordnung
dass sie haben auch viele unserer
Mitglied überhaupt kein Problem mit ich
habe bei mir im Betrieb damit überhaupt
kein Thema weil wir schon deutlich im
übrigen auch über diesen betreten sind
und trotzdem muss es natürlich alles
auch wirtschaftet werden diese diese
Sozialleistung über die wir jetzt reden
sind ja auch getragen von der
Solidargemeinschaft den
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahlern und
da müssen wir einfach auch gucken dass
wir dort auch die Akzeptanz im
beibehalten dass eben
Grundsicherung für Menschen die nichts
beitragen können oder oder wollen das
ist ja und da müssen wir einfach schauen
dass dort die Akzeptanz und das das
Gleichgewicht irgendwie auch erhalten
bleibt aber mit diesen 502 Euro
hier doch genau das also ich kann mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen dass es viele
Menschen gibt die sagen davon kann man
jetzt so toll leben und dass Menschen
sagen da möchte ich dann nicht mehr
arbeiten aber wenn dann gleichzeitig das
Vermögen das Schonvermögen auf 24 Monate
nicht geprüft wird und auch die Wohnung
behalten mit was ja alles vorher anders
war wenn ich dafür 60.000 behalten
sozusagen ich kann 60.000 Euro auf
meinem Konto haben und dann sagen doch
viele ja das doch eigentlich nicht
gerecht ja weil ich glaube
entschuldigung ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich etwas
ein sicherheitssignal er an die
Mittelschicht also dass die Wohnung
sofort weg ist dass man sein Vermögen
sofort los ist das ist ja etwas was ganz
vielen Menschen immer Angst gemacht hat
vor Hartz IV und das ist eigentlich ein
wichtiges Signal gerade in diesen
unruhigen Zeiten an Menschen die
arbeiten die auch für wenig Geld
arbeiten gehen dass Sie wissen wenn dann
was passiert ist nicht gleich alles weg
ich muss nicht sofort umziehen sondern
ich bekomme eine gewisse Zeit wo ich
mich auch darauf konzentrieren kann
neuen Job zu finden hier geht es ja auch
um eine Gruppe die ja auch schon sich
was erwirtschaftet hat da geht es ja um
eine Gruppe die nicht sozusagen
leider in irgendeiner vererbten
Situation ist wo man irgendwie den Weg
noch nicht rausgeschafft hat ja oder wo
man lange arbeitslos ist sondern das
sind ja Leute die sich schon was
geschaffen haben und die genau diese
Angst haben dann ist alles weg und wir
wollen nicht dass die sich damit
beschäftigen müssen am besten noch mit
ihrer ganzen Familie eine Wohnung zu
suchen und was weiß ich was alles
sondern dass die erstmal die Ruhe haben
sich darauf zu konzentrieren wieder in
einen Job zu kommen weil das genau das
ist was sie wollen und die Möglichkeit
zu haben dass mit einer Unterstützung zu
machen manchmal reicht ja auch eine
kleine Qualifikation und gablerschein
oder oder ja was man was man dann so hat
und dann hat man auch wieder seinen Job
und diese Leute eben die Angst zu nehmen
dass man dann alles sozusagen was man
sich ja mal erwirtschaftet hat verliert
wir haben das gesehen in der Pandemie
mit den Selbstständigen ja
das ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger
Schritt Vertrauen zu schaffen und eben
für die die schon lange im System sind
eben mehr auch Möglichkeiten zur
Verfügung zu stellen dass Sie den Weg
eben auch aus aber eben auch bezahlt
werden und 60.000 Euro für die erste
Person im Haushalt und dann bei einer
vierköpfigen Familie summiert sich das
auf 150.000 Euro die auf dem Konto
liegen können und trotzdem gibt es Geld
vom Staat das müssen
szeit
das war ganz Zeit von zwei Jahren und es
ist wirklich
was ja vorher schon Arbeitslosigkeit ist
das heißt wir reden über drei Jahre die
jemand Geld bekommt ohne irgendwie was
dazu beizutragen also die Person hat ja
wahrscheinlich schon gearbeitet oder
selbst wenn sie nicht gearbeitet hat
macht es ja Sinn in die Zukunft einer
solchen Person zu investieren anstatt
sie in irgendwelche Jobs zu zwängen die
sie nicht machen möchte
also
unsere Überzeugung ist die dass wenn ich
mit dieser Angst bis abstiegsbedroht bin
wenn ich damit beschäftigt bin eine neue
Wohnung zu finden wenn ich mich
sozusagen auch in einem neuen in einem
Arbeitslosen Kultur einrichten muss dass
ich mich dann auch immer weiter entferne
vom Arbeitsmarkt und die Idee ist
eigentlich genau diesem diesen Zugang ja
zum Arbeitsmarkt dadurch dass ich auch
erstmal sozial stabilisiere auch nah zu
halten das heißt am Ende des Tages
glaube ich dass es sich rechnet weil die
Leute sehr viel schneller wieder auch in
gute Arbeit müssen damit Steuern zahlen
damit
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge zahlen als
dass sie sozusagen sich dann mal zwei
Jahre zurücklehnen und dann wenn es
ernst wird mal gucken sondern ich glaube
schon dass das gerade in diesen zwei
Jahren auch noch mal so eine Dynamik
dann auslöst eben gerade wieder in den
Job zu kommen aber trotzdem die Frage
wenn man 150.000 Euro auf dem Konto hat
ist es dann nicht zumutbar ein Teil
davon zu nutzen also Sprache in der Not
dann hast du sparen der Zeit dann hast
du in der Not also um dann seine eigene
Notlage auch mit zu finanzieren das wird
man auch tun weil man hat ja dann auch
einen Lebensstandard den man sozusagen
dann mit in die Arbeitslosigkeit bringt
und den wird man mit den 500 zwei Euro
nicht gesichert bekommen und als Familie
schon erst recht nicht das heißt sie
sagen es deswegen ist das Bürgergeld
aber auch nicht genug weil es gibt sehr
viele Menschen die haben keine Rücklagen
wie soll das funktionieren das ist
wirklich meine große Frage weil ich ich
stimme Ihnen zu es ist eine total gute
Verbesserung dass Menschen zwei Jahre
lang ihre Wohnung behalten können dass
sie an schon haben aber was ist mit
denen die das alles nicht gespart haben
was ist mit denen die schon in Wohnungen
leben deren Kosten nicht übernommen
werden deren Heizkosten auch nicht
vollgetragen werden die keine oder wenig
Chancen haben aus diesen Bezug
herauszukommen das ist wirklich die
drängenden Satz finden Sie denn gerecht
der Paritätische Gesamtverband hat es
berechnet und kommt auch 687 Euro und
dann ist es armutsfest und da geht es
darum weil jetzt sind es ja oder es
werden 500 und es ist auch ein Jahr zu
spät die Menschen haben schon super
viele Schulden aufgehäuft man muss sich
klar machen von diesen 450 Euro die bald
500 sind müssen die Menschen auch Strom
bezahlen müssen sie Klamotten bezahlen
Lebensmittel müssen sie Rücklagen bilden
alles mögliche das ist vollkommen
unmöglich man verschuldet sich und
deswegen ist es ja 687 Euro halte ich
für einen angemessenen Betrag und dann
können wir weiterreden
das ist eben Geld das erwirtschaftet
wird auch teilweise von Menschen die
wirklich geringe Einkommen haben und die
ihre Steuern zahlen und da muss man
natürlich genau hinschauen was ist ein
fairer Satz diese Rechnung ist
kompliziert ich gebe zu die ist von
außen auch immer schwer nachvollziehbar
diese 502 Euro sind auf jeden Fall eine
große Verbesserung es ist einfach auch
die Weg ist Ausgleich noch nicht
das ist ja jetzt mal das entscheidende
die wirkliche Verbesserung bei der Art
wie jetzt der Regelsatz berechnet wird
ist dass man früher bei der Inflation
einfach nach hinten geschaut hat und das
nachgeholt hat jetzt schaut man nach
vorne ab dem nächsten Jahr und es wird
etwas vorausberechnet ein Zuschlag
gegeben damit die Inflation im kommenden
Jahr bewältigt werden kann ob das
ausreicht sage ich ehrlich was ich auch
nicht hundertprozentig oder ob man damit
Einmalzahlung noch mal nachsteuern muss
aber ich finde man kann tatsächlich auch
nicht so tun als käme das Geld von
nirgendwo her das zeigen eben auch
Menschen die wirklich für geringe
Einkommen jeden Tag zur Arbeit gehen
die Menschen ein bisschen mehr verdienen
also wenn wir uns sie haben doch gerade
selbst gesagt wir dürfen diese beiden
Gruppen nicht gegeneinander ausspielen
jetzt machen sie ist das verstehe ich
nicht das würde ich so nicht sagen es
ist ja nur nicht so dass man sagen kann
der Regelsatz muss einfach beliebig weit
nach oben gespielt werden das braucht
einfach ein fernausgleich sie wollten
eigentlich mehr die SPD wollte
eigentlich einen höheren Satz und
konnten sich damit aber nicht
durchsetzen das richtig ja ist also wir
diskutieren den Regelsatz ja schon schon
lange und das ist ein technisches
Konstrukt dass es sich nicht lohnt jetzt
hier sozusagen auszubreiten wie man das
bemisst aber er orientiert sich dem
Grunde nach schon an den geringen
Einkommen und das halte ich auch für
richtig es gibt ein paar Stellschrauben
die würde ich anders setzen also jetzt
gesetzt worden sind aber vom Grundsatz
her halte ich das richtig sich an den
Bedarfen und den Ausgaben von
geringverdienten auch aber was
organisiert alleine reagieren würden was
wäre dann wo wir wäre ein Punkt wo sie
sagen dass wir für uns ein guter
Regelsatz ich glaube noch ein Regelsatz
der sich eben genau an denjenigen
orientiert die an gesellschaftlich
teilhaben also es gibt eine Gruppe sehr
gering also von Menschen die gering
verdienen die aber in der Gesellschaft
stattfinden also die teilhaben auch an
dem am gesellschaftlichen Leben und was
wir
gemacht haben oder was wir mit dem
Regelsatz machen ist dass wir den ein
Stück darunter setzen und das führt oft
dazu dass Menschen an gesellschaftlichem
Leben nicht mehr teilhaben können und
ich glaube schon dass diese Teilhabe an
gesellschaftlichen Leben auch etwas ist
was Nähe zum Arbeitsmarkt mit sich
bringt und das ist deswegen auch nicht
nur sozusagen eine Gerechtigkeitsfrage
ist sondern auch eine Frage ist Menschen
in Arbeit zu bringen also wir haben 87
Euro für das glaube ich nicht dass das
sozusagen Dimensionen sind die
finanzierbar sind wenn ich das richtig
im Kopf habe zehn Euro Bürgergeld sind
zwei Milliarden Euro das heißt wir reden
da schon über richtig viel Geld und
insofern glaube ich schon dass wir den
Schwerpunkt auch mit dem was wir
finanziell stemmen darauf setzen müssen
dass die Menschen wieder in Arbeit
kommen und dass sie da eine Perspektive
kriegen und deswegen ist es richtig viel
in ihrer Ausbildung in Unterstützung in
Begleitung zu investieren und deswegen
ist es auch richtig und zu setzen in den
letzten Reize zu setzen nicht nicht in
der also wir haben ja in der letzten
groko den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
sozusagen schon etabliert den werden wir
jetzt entfristen das ist ein ein sehr
sehr erfolgreicher aber nicht gerade
günstiger weg Menschen aber dann auch
wirklich nachhaltig wieder in Arbeit zu
bringen also rechnet sich am Ende auch
die Idee zu sagen kann dass wir
dass wir das was sie sonst bekommen
würden also das heißt dann passiv
aktivtransfer sozusagen mit auch
einfließen zu lassen in diese Bezahlung
von normaler regulärer Arbeit das finde
ich sind schon richtige richtige Ansätze
dort das Geld auch hinzu oder Anreize zu
setzen wie wir es mit dem
weiterbildungsbonus machen wie wir das
damit machen dass man wenn man Prüfungen
besteht auch dafür Boni bekommt und
solche Dinge also da sind ja schon auch
finanzielle Anreize sich anzustrenken
Frau Stein das was würden Sie denn sagen
was brauchen Menschen die jetzt Hartz IV
bekommen und in Zukunft des Bürgergeld
was ist denn ein Anreiz um wieder in
Arbeit zu kommen welche Erfahrungen
haben sie mit der Vermittlung mit all
dem ich habe keine Erfahrung mit der
Arbeitsvermittlung ich mache das
natürlich gar nicht aber ich weiß dass
die Situation der Menschen die Hartz IV
bekommen sehr sehr unterschiedlich sind
und das deswegen ich darauf auch keine
pauschale Antwort geben kann aber es
haben viele Menschen Probleme
nicht weil sie in Hartz4 sind sondern
genau die verursacht haben dass sie in
Hartz IV kommen und die auch dafür
sorgen dass sie länger da bleiben und
häufig brauchen sie mehr als
Arbeitsvermittlung sie brauchen
bestimmte Art von Betreuung und
Personal in sind dann das entsprechend
geschult ist und zudem sie auch
Vertrauen haben und ich glaube nämlich
dass es ein riesengroßer Punkt der
Vertrauen in die Behörde ist nicht da
und die das Vertrauen ist nicht da und
das wird sich auch nicht herstellen
dadurch dass es Bürgergeld genannt wird
weil es muss ein Kulturwandel
stattfinden und ich verstehe noch nicht
so ganz wie der Stadt finden soll wenn
sie mir das erklären können dann bin ich
gespannt aber für mich gehört zu diesem
Kulturwandel eben auch dass man den
Menschen nicht mit leistungserziehung
droht und dass man ihnen ein Geld gibt
mit dem sie leben können und mit denen
auch mit dem auch die Kinder leben
können also wenn man auf der Seite
schaut vom Ministerium dann heißt es
dann mehr Sicherheit weniger Bürokratie
wäre Respekt auch für die Menschen ist
das denn so ein Ansatz wo sie sagen das
ist da das ist ganz wichtig also und
auch das ist Bürgergeld heißt ist das
ein positives Wort ich
ich gebe ihm noch eine Chance dem Wort
ja also es hat ja aber ich es geht nicht
immer darum Menschen in Arbeit zu
vermitteln weil die das nicht zu jeder
Zeit können es geht auch manchmal um was
anderes manche Menschen brauchen Zeit
sich umzuorientieren oder sich zu
erholen oder die Situation zu Hause zu
stabilisieren das muss man eben auch
bedenken und da geht es nicht immer nur
darum zu sagen ja aber die Person muss
schnell arbeiten damit ihr auch ja nicht
den Steuerzahlen auf der Tasche liegt
das ist einfach zu kurz gedacht weil
diese Menschen werden krank genau das
ändern wir ja also Sie haben ja das
richtige Stichwort gesagt Sie haben ja
gesagt die die Gründe sind sehr
unterschiedlich und genau deswegen haben
wir ja jetzt diesen individuellen Ansatz
gewählt wo wir uns erstmal angucken was
was bringt diese die Person mit
an Fähigkeiten an Möglichkeiten aber
auch an Beschwerden müssen um die man
sich kümmern muss und da ist zum
Beispiel vorher auch so dass
das war doch vorher auch so dann mussten
die Leute in irgendwelche Computerkurse
oder bewerbungsgesucht genau und der ist
entscheidend
dass wir eben genau individuell gucken
und nicht gucken welche Kurse sind da
sondern wir gucken was braucht diese
Person wirklich für ihren Weg und wir
nehmen eben nicht diesen kurzen Weg
sondern wir nehmen auch wenn es nötig
ist einen langen Weg und das ist das ist
das entscheidende weil Frau Steinhaus
hat vollkommen Recht die Unterschiede
sind manchmal sind auch viele Dinge die
zusammenkommen warum jemand nicht
arbeiten kann ganz oft sind
gesundheitliche Fragen die auch erstmal
gelöst werden müssen und genau das zu
verabreden in dieser
Kooperationsvereinbarung die beide
sozusagen miteinander beschließen wo
nicht einer sagt so läuft's ja und dann
wird das so gemacht sondern wo man sich
gemeinsam hinsetzt und gemeinsam einen
Weg mit Schritten definiert wie man
sozusagen sein Leben wieder in Griff
kriegt Schulden in den Griff kriegt
Gesundheit in den Griff kriegt Familie
in den Griff kriegt und wir haben mit
dem sozialen Arbeitsmarkt dafür ein
Instrument gehabt und haben das immer
noch das Coaching das begleitende
Coaching schon haben damit ein riesen
Erfolg und deswegen wollen wir genau
dieses begleitende Coaching das einfach
ein bisschen hilft diese Dinge zu
bewältigen die für manche für uns ist
das nicht immer vorstellbar aber für
viele Menschen einfach große Hürden sind
dabei ihr Leben zu organisieren das
weiten wir aus so dass das auch nicht
nur für diejenigen die im sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt sind zur Verfügung steht
sondern auch für diejenigen die zum
Beispiel sich vorgenommen haben eine
Ausbildung zu machen oder auch nur
andere Probleme in den Griff zu kriegen
Peter trauen sieht es der Arbeitsagentur
zu wir haben jetzt 20 Jahre dieses Hartz
IV gehabt wir sind mit vielen Dingen da
nicht besonders erfolgreich gewesen ist
das und jetzt soll es sozusagen so ein
kompletten Wechsel da geben kann das
funktionieren
das ist auf jeden Fall ein ganz dickes
Brett das gebohrt werden muss da muss
man glaube ich den Mitarbeitern auch
helfen das wird nicht alles von einem
Tag auf den anderen gehen interessant
ist ja dass wir mit Andrea Nahles jetzt
eine Chefin bei der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit haben die sich dieses Konzept des
Bürgergeldes ausgedacht hat also das war
vor ich glaube dreieinhalb Jahren dass
die SPD ihr sozialstaatskonzept wie
lassen wir Hartz IV hinter uns
entwickelt haben damals zwar Andrea
Nahles noch SPD-Vorsitzende aber das
wird am Anfang in der Praxis sicher
schon auch noch Probleme geben und da
muss man dann kritisch hinschauen und
schauen wo muss man Dinge anpassen und
ich finde auch bei den Sanktionen muss
man tatsächlich immer im Blick behalten
was funktioniert dann tatsächlich in der
Praxis also ich würde auch sagen am
schönsten ist es wenn es gar keine
Sanktionen gibt wenn man die nicht
braucht wenn man mit Mitarbeitern im
Jobcentern spricht dann sagen die halt
schon das was ich für meine Arbeit
brauche ist natürlich dass Menschen auch
zu mir herkommen und wenn die nie
herkommen dann brauche ich auch
irgendeinen Mittel um das zu ändern und
das Frau Steinhaus leuchtet mir dann
schon auch ein also da sagen Sie es
macht dann schon Sinn dass man
Sanktionen hat genau die Sanktion werden
ja auch nicht komplett abgeschafft die
Frage ist in welchem System fordert man
diese Mitwirkung ein und wir sagen eben
nicht du kriegst einen Brief und wenn du
nicht kommst dann Batch sondern du
kriegst den briefum wenn du dann nicht
kommst gucken wir warum du nicht kommst
aber was heißt dann gucken wir warum
nicht anders aufsuchende Arbeit das ist
auch jetzt schon möglich und wird auch
teilweise gemacht das heißt der
Mitarbeiter geht zu demjenigen und genau
oder man oder man macht das eben mit dem
Quartiers Management mit denen die vor
Ort auch sozusagen die Leute die Leute
kennen die Zugang haben in den
unterschiedlichen
Bereichen dass die sozusagen das
rausfinden weil wir haben oft die
Situation das psychische Probleme der
Grund sind und dann ist man ganz schnell
in so einer Abwärtsspirale wenn man sich
nicht meldet und so weiter und man aber
allgemeine stärkere Betreuung Coaching
all das
Schröder wenn Sie das so hören denken
sie dass ich kann sich die Gesellschaft
das leisten jeden und muss sich die
Gesellschaft das leisten weil wir die
ganzen Arbeitskräfte brauchen unbedingt
ich denke die Gesellschaft sollte sich
leisten Menschen die wollen auch wieder
in Arbeit zurückzubringen und dazu
zählen eben auch Begleitungen über
Coaching über psychotherapeutische
Maßnahmen und so weiter unbedingt das
Arbeitsplatz zumindest das finde ich gut
und geht auch gut bieten ja auch viele
Unternehmen was wenn die Menschen in
Arbeit sind bieten die bieten ja auch
viele Unternehmen mittlerweile dort
Begleitung an also das finde ich gut ob
es der Behörde gelingt schlussendlich
also da wie Herr Peter sagte ein extrem
dickes Brett zu bohren die
behaarungskräfte von deutschen Behörden
sind ja bekannt und da kann ich nur uns
gemeinsam auch die Daumen drücken dass
das sich dort wirklich auch Bewegung
dass das wirklich auch zu Bewegung führt
und zu Veränderungen also
ganz ernsthaft ich habe es ist unter
anderem mein Beruf aber ich habe das
letzte Woche erlebt als ich auf der
Betriebsversammlung meines Jobcenters
war und mit den MitarbeiterInnen
Mitarbeitern über das Bürgergeld
diskutiert habe die wollen das die
wollen die Möglichkeiten haben mehr
Möglichkeiten haben weil die kennen ja
alle sozusagen die Situation von ganz
vielen Menschen die bei ihnen sind und
wir müssen ihnen die Zeit geben sich
umzustellen aber ich weiß das von ganz
vielen dass die genauso wie wir ihn
jetzt das auch ermöglichen wollen auch
selber gerne arbeiten wollen und
insofern bin ich sehr optimistisch dass
die Jobcenter das wirklich auch gut
umgesetzt kriegen ich glaube das sofort
weil ich kenne auch viele Menschen im
Jobcenter arbeiten und die sagen dass
das wirklich schwierig ist mit diesem
Gesetz Hartz IV
an Menschen ranzukommen und die auch in
Arbeit zu bringen und trotzdem haben die
auch über eine sehr lange Zeit gelernt
mit zum Beispiel den Mittel der
Sanktionen Menschen
zu versuchen irgendwo hinzubringen und
ich glaube auch da muss es muss man
Alternativen schaffen da machen wir was
wäre denn eine Alternative machen was
konkret ich gebe als Mitarbeiter des
Jobcenters lade ich jemanden ein zu
einem Gespräch der kommt nicht was mache
ich dann also es gibt ja zum Beispiel
versuche in den Jobcenter
Einladung mit und ohne sanktions
Androhung geschickt haben und am Ende
rausgekommen es sind genauso viele Leute
zum Termin gekommen mit oder ohne
Einladung also es macht keinen
Unterschied genau die Sanktionen die
bringen Studie mitverantwortlich genau
von Sanktion vielleicht sagen Sie uns
mal rausgekommen ist ja die Studie zeigt
dass eben Sanktionen Menschen nicht in
Arbeit bringen das ist die offizielle
behauptete
behauptete Wirkung die Sanktionen haben
sollen und auch müssen das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt wenn sie
diese Wirkung nicht nachweisen können
dann sind sie verfassungswidrig sie
dürfen nicht als Strafe verwendet werden
und genau es ist rausgekommen die
Sanktionen verfehlen ihre Wirkung was
sie aber tun ist Menschen unter Druck zu
setzen sie sind auch kontraproduktiv sie
tun alles mögliche aber sie bringen
Menschen nicht in Arbeit und aber
ausdrücklich die Sanktionen für zulässig
erklärt also das ist ausdrücklich sie
dann für zulässig erklärt wenn sie ihre
Wirkung
erbringen die Wirkung soll seinen
Menschen Arbeit zu bringen funktioniert
nicht ich weiß nicht ob es ja auch
andere Studien die das Studien die sagen
aber im Endbericht auch ich bringe die
Sanktionen die Menschen in Arbeit ist in
der Studie vom IAB und nach kurzer Zeit
sitzen die Menschen wieder im Jobcenter
das ist ja drehtoreffekt weil sie in
Jobs gepresst werden die sie nicht
machen möchten die sie nicht machen
können damit den sie unglücklich sind
und ihr Leben einfach so genau das ist
ja der Punkt den wir beenden so und
deswegen wenn wir sowas aufstellen wie
wir das jetzt machen ja mit den ganzen
Instrumenten wovon wir als Gesellschaft
glaube ich insgesamt profitieren dann
ist es sozusagen auch notwendig dass das
worauf man sich dann verabredet hat und
das was man gemeinsam entwickelt hat
dass das dann auch gemacht wird und dass
man das auch einfordern kann und ich
glaube so eine Vertrauenskultur zu
schaffen aber gleichzeitig auch eine
Erwartungshaltung zu haben und ich finde
das auch richtig eine Erwartungshaltung
zu haben weil ich finde es auch würdelos
zu sagen von dir erwarte ich nichts mehr
ja sondern zu sagen ich erwarte dass Du
Dich einbringst und wir unterhalten uns
aber darüber was was geht was kannst du
was möchtest du was bringst du mit was
sind deine Stärken und wir gucken auch
was du schon in deinem Leben ja alles
gemacht hast ja auch wenn du vielleicht
kein kein Zertifikat für eine Ausbildung
hast ja hast du ja trotzdem vielleicht
Kompetenzen die wir nutzen können so und
ich glaube dass dieser herangegangen
dass das schon ein ganz anderes Klima
erzeugt in dem es dann was weiß ich nur
die die dann wirklich die hartnäckigen
sind dann dann noch sozusagen sich
verweigert Herr Peter was was kann man
erwarten von jemandem der Arbeit sucht
und ist sind die Sanktionen auch deshalb
vielleicht wichtig oder werden noch
genutzt damit der andere Steuerzahler
nicht das Gefühl haben die können sich
darauf ausruhen
also zum einen muss man sagen am besten
ist es natürlich tatsächlich wenn
Sanktionen so gestaltet sind dass sie
wirkungsvoll sind ich fand ihre Studie
sehr sehr interessant und ich finde auch
sie ist ein wichtiger Beitrag man muss
dazu sagen dass jetzt massefraktischer
vom die wie der bei der Vorstellung der
Studie zu gegen war ja auch gesagt hat
man braucht da noch mal ein etwas
breiteren wissenschaftlichen
Rundumschlag um da in die Tiefe zu gehen
am Ende ist es aus meiner Sicht schon
auch so dass es nicht nur darum geht ist
die Sanktionen
unfassbar wirksam sondern es geht schon
auch ein Stück weit um Gerechtigkeit ich
finde schon man kann ab einem bestimmten
Punkt von Menschen auch ein Mindestmaß
an Kooperation erwarten und ich finde
das können auch die Menschen die Steuern
zahlen und ich sage das noch mal und ich
will da wirklich keine Menschen
gegeneinander ausspielen aber auch die
auch die Krankenschwester die hart
arbeitet finanziert ist alles mit und
ich finde ein Mindestmaß an Kooperation
kann man erwarten und das finde ich
wirklich auch gerecht weil da wird immer
so da das Bild erzeugt dass die also
dass Menschen sanktioniert werden die
sich ganz fürchterlich schlecht
Verhalten und die die zu Hause sitzen
und Chips essen also eben dieser
Klischee Hartz IV Empfänger und das
stimmt einfach nicht es werden so viele
Menschen sanktioniert die sage ich mal
auch in unseren Augen nicht falsch
gemacht hätten und nicht besonders gut
ja aber es sind viele ideal okay aber
hinter diesen drei Prozent stehen viele
Menschen und und alle bekommen diese
sanktions Androhungen und auch das macht
viel mit den Menschen
also wenn jemand alles macht ja er wird
eingeladen zum Beispiel ohne kommt dann
ja aber
trotzdem nicht zum Termin dann kommt er
trotzdem nicht zum Termin dann ruft man
noch mal an ob man die Person vielleicht
erreicht weil vielleicht kann sie zu dem
Termin nicht oder mal sonst selber nicht
an
oder
es gibt die Möglichkeit ich habe das
eben gesagt weil das haben wir oft
wirklich auch gemeldet bekommen von von
Jobcentern oder auch von von
arbeitsloseninitiativen dass Menschen
wirklich aufgrund gesundheitlicher
Probleme nicht kommen können dann ist es
wichtig dass man eben gucken das weiß
dass man das weiß warum kommt die Person
nicht das könnte die Person aber
mitteilen okay genau so was passiert
auch das Personen das mitteilen aber
sowas wird teilweise also da gibt es
auch diesen Messungen Ermessensspielraum
und dann wird es teilweise nicht
anerkannt obwohl zum Beispiel
Krankschreibung vorliegen dann wird
verlangt dass die Menschen zum Arzt
gehen Sie sich eine
wegeunfähigkeitsbescheinigung anschaffen
solche Sachen hatten erst im Winter
diesen Jahres den Fall von einer Frau
die eine Knieverletzung hatte und nicht
zum Jobcenter gehen konnte auf dem Dorf
gewohnt hat es klingt als würde ich mir
auf denkt ausdenken das stimmt aber die
war krankgeschrieben und braucht eine
wegeunfähigkeitsbescheinigung mit ihrer
Knieverletzung das ist doch absurd und
wie will man das verhindern mit mir
schreiben Kinder dass sie versuchen ihre
Familien zu unterstützen weil ihre
Mütter teilweise es nicht mehr schaffen
die Briefe aufzumachen und nicht
anzugehen und dadurch werden die
sanktioniert und die Sanktionen treffen
auch die Kinder in der Familie und das
kann man einfach nicht verhindern nie
also es wird es wird einen ersten Moment
geben müssen wo man einfach mal
miteinander in Kontakt tritt genau also
genau dann diese weiteren Dinge zu
verabreden und dann haben wir ja genau
dieses ganze dann haben wir ja genau
dieses ganze Breite Instrumentarium wenn
ich gar nicht in Kontakt trete dann kann
ich ja eigentlich ja wenn du noch drei
Minuten
hören was ist denn gerecht also was er
ist auch das Unternehmersicht gerecht
wie sich jemand verhält
gerechtes auf keinen Fall dass alles
gleich ist also wir brauchen diese diese
Leistungsdifferenzierung wir brauchen
diese einkommensdifferenzierung also da
kann ich die Forderungen von Frau
Steinhaus nicht nachvollziehen das so
wie Gehälter einfach angehoben werden
sollen so funktioniert hier diese dieses
System nicht und
wir sind ganz neugierig was jetzt
passiert also wir brauchen Menschen die
arbeiten möchten und wir sind ganz
gespannt was jetzt dort durch das neue
Bürgergeld passiert als Unternehmer dazu
beitragen dass es einfacher ist dass man
miteinander sozusagen zusammenkommt
ich glaube die Zusammenarbeit mit den
Arbeitsagenturen da geht glaube ich ganz
viel schon auch in den in den in den
direkten Gesprächen zwischen den
Personalabteilungen und den
Arbeitsagenturen also wir haben da gute
Erfahrungen gemacht
ja ansonsten glaube ich ist da jetzt
aufgrund des großen Bedarfes an an
Arbeitskräften ist da glaube ich jetzt
gar nicht so viel Problemlage und in der
Welt also da geht es noch ein bisschen
mehr Mut für den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
wünschen also dass sie auch noch mehr
Arbeitsplätze auch im Bereich des
sozialen Arbeitsmarktes in der
Privatwirtschaft zur Verfügung stellen
weil auch da so viele Erfolgsgeschichten
mittlerweile gibt dass das glaube ich in
wirklich guter Weg ist ja oder Praktika
zur Verfügung stellen alles das ja
Menschen eine Chance geben also für uns
ist diese Balance eben wichtig dass wir
gucken dass die sozial die
Grundsicherung dass das was von
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahlern
bezahlt wird dass das irgendwo auch in
einem in einem vernünftigen sage ich mal
Kontext auch zu der Grund steht das ist
wirklich der Abstand und das ist dort
wirklich auch ein sozialen
gesellschaftlichen Konsens dazu gibt ja
also das ist ja auch schon angesprochen
worden dass die Wünsche der
Sozialverbände sind natürlich immer groß
das ist ja auch in Ordnung aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir eben gucken wie
das auch bezahlt wird und dieser
Staatshaushalt hat ja so viele Aufgaben
also das muss einfach auch alles im
Rahmen bleiben im Rahmen heißt dann dass
die Menschen hungern das ist ihnen klar
oder dass Sie Ihre Stromrechnung nicht
bezahlen müssen dass der Strom
abgestellt wird das ist die Realität von
Menschen die Hartz IV bekommen die
Grundsicherung und die Kosten die dazu
übernommen werden die muss vom Regelsatz
bezahlt werden das ist völlig absurd das
können die Leute nicht bezahlen das ist
leider so aber würden Sie denn sagen
oder dass Menschen die Hartz IV bekommen
hungern oft ja
wie würden sie es beurteilen
ich glaube man sollte nicht so tun als
wüsste man wie die Situation ist mit
diesem Regelsatz auszukommen ich musste
das persönlich nie ich kenne Leute die
von Hartz IV gelebt haben das ist
insbesondere auch bei Menschen die einen
Job hatten die in ganz anderes Leben
hatten und wenn es dann immer immer
schlechter wird ist es eine ganz ganz
bittere Geschichte ich würde schon immer
sagen man muss einfach auch sehen dass
der Regelsatz jetzt wirklich steigt ich
sage auch man muss angesichts der
Inflation angesichts von Energiepreisen
auch wirklich im Blick behalten ob man
im nächsten Jahr mit weiteren Hilfen
nachsteuern muss das gilt für Menschen
in der Grundsicherung das gilt auch für
Geringverdiener da befinden wir uns
einfach in der Situation die wir auf ein
Jahr nicht komplett beurteilen können
und das muss man im Blick haben auch
schwierig wird gerade angesichts der
steigenden Energiekosten wo wir alle
nicht wissen wie sich das entwickelt
vielen Dank für die Diskussion Frau
Schmid später Frau Steinhaus und Herr
Schröter und im Oktober ungefähr kommt
das wahrscheinlich ins Parlament und
dann reden wir bestimmt auch noch mal
darüber morgen schauen wir auf die
Weltlage Scholze oder Bundeskanzler
redet vor der UN-Vollversammlung der
fragen wir mal was kann die Welt von
Deutschland erwarten und jetzt folgt
Phoenix der Tag mit Anja Chalet bis dann
tschüss
[Musik]